we are extraordinarily fortunate to have
16 speakers who
answered the call to give lightning
talks for stoicon
2020 midwest it's excellent that we have
so many people who are willing to give
lightning talks and
all of these are pre-recorded so i have
lined them up
one after another it also produces a few
challenges as far as staying
on track and on time so what i've
decided to do
is instead of giving individual
introductions to each speaker
before they talk i'm just going to say
i'm so happy to have all of them here
and we are going to prepare
a document that'll have bios and the
links where you can find each of these
speakers
if you're interested and we'll be
sending that out to you
in the next few days or so i don't want
to say anything more because i don't
want to take up any more time just sit
back
relax and enjoy learning about stoicism
and all sorts of interesting experiences
and features
and insights from our great lineup of
lightning talk speakers
everyone my name is ben aldridge and
stoicism has had a profound
effect on my life several years ago
seemingly out of the blue i was hit with
severe and debilitating
anxiety and i didn't understand what was
happening to me
when i started having panic attacks i
had no systems
in place to deal with this so this led
me on a bit of a quest to try and
understand
how to manage this anxiety how i can
deal with it
so i started reading extensively on
mental health on
psychology on philosophy all of these
different subjects
and this is where i discovered stoicism
and
one aspect of stoicism in particular had
a huge impact
on me and that's the concept of
voluntary discomfort
now the stoics were very creative and
they would deliberately
step outside of their comfort zones in
order to build mental resilience
and they would do this in brilliant ways
they would expose themselves to the cold
to the heat they would fast from food
and water
and sleep on hard surfaces and this
really inspired me this really resonated
with me
so i started to test out this concept
and at first i was very very anxious so
i tried in a very
simple small way by pushing myself out
of my comfort zone
and then over time this built up and i
started to complete challenges
and i started to expose myself to
adversity
as a in a controlled environment and the
more i did this the more confident
i became and this this concept of
voluntary discomfort
had such a huge effect on me and
my anxiety my relationship with my
anxiety completely changed
i learned what tools and tricks i could
use to deal with it
and this stoic framework has been so
important to me
that i've written a book about it it's
called how to be comfortable with being
uncomfortable and the concept is
exploring all of these different things
that
i've been doing to step out of my
comfort zone and how
stepping into discomfort can teach us a
lot about who we are and how we manage
difficulty and adversity and this is
really why stoicism has changed my life
and why it's something that
i continue to study and there's been
many more ideas
within the philosophy that have helped
me to live a better life
the idea of negative visualization some
of the concepts on
control what we can and can't control
and how we respond to
external events and all of these
different things have had
a very positive impact on my mental
health
and that's why i believe that stoicism
is so important and i'm really really
excited
to be able to share some of my
ideas on stoicism and how it's helped me
personally
and i believe that the concept of
voluntary discomfort in particular
can be great for us it can be a really
empowering thing
when we step outside of our comfort
zones and can see
that we are gaining confidence when we
can do these things that are difficult
and
learning how to manage that difficulty
anyway thank you so much for
listening and i encourage you to push
yourself out of your comfort zone and
maybe try a stoic challenge maybe have a
cold shower
or maybe get into fasting or try all
these different things
and see how that has an effect on your
mindset
thank you
when we experience hardship we are
encouraged
to read the stoics and to start
journaling but while we go all the way
back to the ancient stoic
texts and read from there our
understanding of
how to journal is much more contemporary
our method of journaling is mostly
informed by the pioneering work of james
pennebaker
who in around the 80s taught a method
called
expressive writing a kind of free form
journaling
as a way of thinking through an issue
identifying
emotional reactions to an issue making
sense of it and finding a way forward
now the penta baker idea is that you
write about a single issue that's
bothering you you write for brief
stretches of time
say 15 to 20 minutes and you write
consecutively for one to five days
and you stop writing when the issue
stops troubling you
now the only problem with that is that
some problems don't
stop troubling us we cannot change them
and we cannot leave them we are stuck
with them
at least for a certain period of time
with these
ongoing problems than the temptation
really
is to keep writing page after page after
page
and while the cathartic hit
or release of getting it all down on
paper is satisfying
endless rumination is the last thing
that we want
now the type of self-writing or
self-help writing that we find in marcus
aurelius differs significantly from the
expressive writing method that we
inherited from pennebaker for one thing
there's hardly
any personal references in the text for
another there's no
account of personal anguish no dramatic
accounts of confrontation with
other people and no confessions of anger
which we
have which we find in seneca's letters
all marcus aurelius does is rewrite
re-express and reformulate
uh the stoic doctrines he's basically
paraphrasing
so i left my freeform journaling to
journal with marcus aurelius
and here's an example of one journaling
session first i open up the meditations
i'll read a section quietly to myself
i'll copy it out in my journal literally
copy it out word
for word this really just helps me slow
down
and it helps me focus my attention on
the text itself
instead of on how the text relates to
me which is a subtle but extraordinary
difference
now once i've copied the text i still
have more work to do i need
to make these teachings these doctrines
these maxims speak loud and clear to me
pierre hadeau talks about rhetorical
amplification
and this just means how to make words
and meanings sound
more amplified to your own personal ear
which enhances your own comprehension
and
memorization of a text
so back to marcus aurelius i look at
words
and um rhetoric i do some summarizing
i do some rewriting and reformulating or
paraphrasing of the text now if i'm able
to come up with
a spectacularly good re-ex re-expression
i'll transfer it either to some wall art
or to my own pocket handbook
i've created a little pocket-sized
handbook my own enthusiasm my own
handbook for
life which is precisely what epictetus
instructed his own students
to do now journaling with marcus
aurelius in this way
helped me formulate rules for life and
not just
solutions for specific problems i've
been able to engage
much more intensely with the
or the stoic teachings and i've also
been able to memorize
more of the teachings which means that
when i head back
out into the world i'm actually equipped
with a stoic toolbox which i can use
now marcus aurelius goes over the same
issues again and again but
in an ever more eloquently expressed way
and sometimes with remarkably vivid
imagery just to make the teachings ever
more memorable
memorization is key because you need to
take the doctrines with you
as always to have them as epictetus says
always at hand
in book 3 section 2 of the meditations
mark australius writes
we should also attend to things like
these observing that even the incidental
effects of the processes of nature
have their own charm and attraction take
the baking of bread
the loaf splits open here and there and
those very cracks
in one way a failure of the baker's
provision somehow catch the eye
and give particular stimulus to our
appetite
now i don't know how much of a baker
marcus aurelius was but if you have any
affinity for the hobby of bread baking
like like i do then i'm sure you
appreciate the attention that that
marcus is giving here
in the imagery that he invokes the
splintering of the crust
as the dough swells beneath the bread
bursting forth
in this array this mosaic of
fractures and protuberances that are
unique
to to that loaf and though
these cracks might not have been
intended by the baker
they are inescapable parts of the baking
process
a little bit of nature etching itself
into the very crust of the bread
and this is not the only part of the
bread baking process
that we can sort of find such beauty in
if we reflect a bit more on on the
nature of of the activity there's a lot
that could be said
in book six of his nekomarkian ethics
aristotle
discusses three different types of
activities
each with a corresponding intellectual
virtue which guides it
now two of these virtues are related to
practical reasoning one of them is
related to theoretical reasoning but
none of them are mutually exclusive
instead they all come together in unique
ways
which sort of informs the unfolding of
any given
activity and can lend some understanding
in our case to this
mystical art of do punching
first of all we have poison making
which is an act of production guided by
the
intellectual virtue of techne art or
crafts person shift
this is the this is the knowledge and
the skill of the baker
who knows the correct methodology to
kneading
who knows the the ratio of flour to
water
and also knows when to take the bun out
of the oven so that it doesn't get burnt
at the opposite end of the spectrum we
have the
you know from the more practical
orientation we have theory
or contemplation which is an act of
meditation guided by
sophia the pure rationality of
theoretical wisdom
and this is the knowledge marker shares
in in his meditation
in in a philosophical exercise or
escapes
that pierre ordo would have spoken about
in terms of
the concentration of of the eye
bracketing all
peripheral considerations to focus on
the detail of the present moment
you know on the cracks of the bread and
how they manifest
the reason of nature
as a type of ascasis or philosophical
exercise
what aurelius is discussing would would
implicitly have some sort of ethical
significance
so what does this have to teach us about
moral virtue
well firstly patience you know baking
bread is not
immediate gratification it
and this also reveals something about
our relationship to food
not only to bread but food in general
and what and how we eat you know
if we could be more attentive to that
relationship
practicing what we could call mindful
eating
it could only serve to foster temperance
bread baking then can also be considered
a praxis
and start up with the practical wisdom
of prudence
so my challenge to you then is not to
undertake
the practice of bread baking this only
represents one form of philosophical
exercises
amongst many and what i would rather
encourage you to do is
reflect on the activities that make up
any given day or week
in your life consider how you could
better understand the nature and nuances
of those chores and
how we could elevate those beyond
being mundane errands to opportunities
for contemplation and personal
affirmation
so thank you for including me in these
presentations i hope everyone has been
having a great stoke week
take care and happy practice
howdy my name is steve karafett i am a
biology lecturer at the university of
central arkansas
and i have been podcasting on stoicism
for almost four years
the purpose of this talk podcasting as a
stoic practice is to encourage you to
consider
podcasting as a means to learn about
this philosophy but also to practice the
virtues
embodied by this philosophy
stoicism needs your voice we are working
on a cosmopolis
a world wide stoic family
and if a lot of our representatives are
silent
we won't hear from you so no matter who
you are you have some unique perspective
your voice can be shared and i encourage
you to consider podcasting as a way of
sharing
that voice one of the virtues we can
cultivate by podcasting is wisdom
and my recommendation is to approach it
like socrates
understand that you don't know anything
don't come at it as
as if you're a guru on a hill and
everyone's coming to you to learn from
the master
you are just another individual learning
along with them and if you frame it that
way
people will come along for the ride it's
impossible to begin to learn
that which you think you know already
and at the same time
teaching is a very powerful tool because
it helps
you to learn seneca knew this 2000 years
ago
research in pedagogy now shows the same
thing
so what i like to do when i have a
difficult topic is
figure out how i would explain it to a
child figure out how
i would explain it to an adult and then
imagine how
a stoic who has been practicing for two
or three hundred years might explain it
to me and then i put that all together
and try to then explain it to my
audience
podcasting is your chance to practice
the virtue of justice
it's your chance to share your unique
interest your unique viewpoint with the
world
but it's important to do so in an honest
way be honest with your listeners
telling them what you don't know is a
strength because
they will see themselves in you
and and one thing that's very humbling
about
podcasting is you may well affect the
lives of others
folks who are looking for stoicism as a
guide to help them live a better life
and you will be one of their guides
even though you are in the bed next to
them in the hospital as seneca might say
giving them the advice you've been given
they will see you as someone who has
influenced them
it's your chance to practice this virtue
we are all made for one another and we
can teach them
or we can bear with them i like to teach
i think you could teach them as well
temperance is something you might want
to have on hand as a stoic podcaster as
well
why because you're going to have to keep
to a schedule
don't just say i will podcast oh a
couple times a month
set a schedule know what it is ahead of
time and stick to it
and also this is a good chance to
practice listening rather than talking
if you have guests on your show
and it's a chance to practice reading
deeply instead of just skimming and
pretending you know stoicism start to
read
deeply epictetus says consider the first
steps to it and what follows
and then if it is to your advantage and
if so
lay your hand to the work so think about
it do you have the ability to
put ideas together do you have a phone
that you can record these ideas on
then perhaps you have the means and the
ability
to podcast
you will also need to practice the
virtue of fortitude or courage
if you're going to podcast you're likely
to get feedback
some of it will be flattering you so
you'll have to think about how to deal
with that
but also there will be critical feedback
you can learn from it grow from it
you can learn what to ignore as well
and a big one there will be technical
issues
you're going to have a famous guest on
and their microphone won't work or your
recorder won't work
but you can deal with it you can
practice the virtues and get through it
if you want to consider podcasting i
highly recommend
anchor dot fm or the program audacity
but if you have any questions on getting
started email me sunday stoic
gmail.com and seize the day carpe diem
hey guys thank you for asking me to
speak at stoichionics midwest
for my lightning talk today i would like
to discuss the future of modern stoicism
however before we go into the future we
must first discuss the past
zeno founded the first school of
stoicism the school continued after
several generations and had multiple
leaders
eventually more stoked schools opened up
throughout the known world
in time though with the growth of the
church philosophy fell out of favor
so let's move to modern times
having been linked with cognitive
behavioral therapy modern stoicism has
also gained a rather large following in
its own right
the modern stoicism movement has been
very therapeutic for many people
as the years go by more and more stoic
groups are being formed
currently listed on the stoic fellowship
website are over 90
individual stoic groups around the world
although much of the world is still not
covered
each year more and more stoichonax
events have been made available to the
public
and now being able to utilize the
virtual environment we can reach a
global audience
stoic virtue requires that if we are
able to help others
that we must my dream for the future is
this
for those who do not belong to a stoic
group join one
or if there are no groups in your area
be courageous
and create one the sharing of knowledge
is the best way to achieve wisdom
we are all students on the path to
virtue
let us help each other become teachers
of the next generation
let us work together to create a
cosmopolitan society
let us bring back the concept of the
stoic school
we have taken the first steps let us now
go just a little bit further
thank you
hello dears this is claudia torres from
brazil
and i would like to tell you about my
great experience
studying stoicism with the weekly group
of milwaukee stoic fellowship
this group is coordinated by a great guy
called dan hayes
he's a very very patient guy when i
began studying with them
my english was terrible terrible so
terrible that i forgot
many words in the the sentence i was
talking you know and he was very very
patient with me and this was something
that
really touched me because um
we don't see that usually right and
also we began to study
marcus aurelius you know and
i saw how he also
is very patient with things that usually
our culture does not incentivize us to
be you know
and i was very touched by
these these lessons and i
i started to apply
the stoic directives in my life with
great results dichotomy of control
is something that should be taught in
primary school you know because it's so
important for our lives
it makes us stop being so
sentimental you know and
more focused in our own lives
more focused in what we can really do to
help
um people around us
but um respecting them you know
understanding that each person has
their own way of being and
um this was so great for me that i
decided to
put up my own group here in my country
a group in portuguese using the same
method
that dan had showed me you know and
i began gathering people through
internet you know
and we do a weekly meeting on mondays
and it's been very very nice for us
for me for them you know and
one of the boys that came knew some
people in angola
and he invited me to talk to them one
day
and i told dan about that right
in the next day dan and shan you know
it's
a very nice to have these two people
there always
and they told me you can't put up
a stock on x in brazil and i said oh my
god can i really do that
and boy i got energy you know i went
out and about and i started talking to
people
i made friendships in linkedin
linkedin linkedin with
um with donald robertson
and with greg sadler
you know and then i started to invite
them
to come and and talk to us here
and then greg lopez that had received me
in the stoic
um fellowship the big stoic
fellowship he presented me to
aldo dinucci that works with
stoicism in brazil he translated
directly from greek
and he presented me other people and the
result
is that now tomorrow the 25th
we will have the first toy connects
brazil
with 16 speakers
we have already 130 registered people
today this is wednesday i'm talking to
you you know
and um it's been a very very great
experience because
i have got more control of myself
my depression i have had a problem with
anxiety
and depression in the last four years
and i'm getting to control myself better
even when i get out of of of
mind you know i return more quickly
and plus i have made many many
friendship many friends like um
good-hearted people and i really
recommend that
everyone have this experience because it
has been
very very nice thank you all so very
much
enjoy stoic um stoic connects
midwest and maybe we'll see each other
next year
in person bye bye
hello fellow stoics i decided to do my
virtual lightning round talk about a
virtually
random topic i thought well the stoicons
are usually in the 10th month of the
year so i would just talk about
whatever happens to be in the 10th
chapter of epictetus's
handbook so i picked up and produced a
few english translations and it
basically says something like this for
each thing that happens to you
remember to turn to yourself and ask
yourself
what powers you have for dealing with it
if you see a beautiful woman
or man you will find self-control for
that
if hardship should come your way you'll
find the power of endurance for that
if you are abused you will find patience
now if you habituate yourself to this if
you get used to doing this
then you will no longer be carried away
by impressions
uh by your my appearances by your first
impressions of external events
so that is the gist of that entire uh
10th chapter and i love this little
chapter
for multiple reasons one is the way
appetitus talks about
our powers now some translations will
say are capacities
or faculties these are legitimate
translations of epithelius greek word of
dunamis from which we derive words like
dynamo dynamic
and dynamite so it does refer to
inherent
faculties or capacities or powers that
we can develop within ourselves
now part reason i love this too
is epictetus is probably best known for
talking about what we could call our
power with a capital b
the power of pro-heresis or rational
capacity to choose things to select
how we act and think and feel in
response to what's going on around us
and sometimes maybe even
in spite of what's going on around us in
fact
just above this 10th chapter in the
brief ninth chapter of the handbook
it's all about uh proaeresis so in a way
i like to think of this tenth chapter
is showing the small p powers that flow
from that big p
power of proparesis and it gives us just
three examples of
self-control endurance and patience now
these kind of powers are also referred
to
as virtues and some philosophers call
virtues
perfections of our power so it's
wonderful how these all
come together but how do we perfect
these powers how do we build these
powers
within us to become full-fledged virtues
well epictetus gives us advice here too
in this small little excerpt
he says if you get used to doing this or
in some translations if you
habituate yourself to doing this then
you won't be carried away by your
impressions well
virtues are also referred to as habits
you know virtues are good habits and the
way that vices
are bad habits so tedious is telling us
to build up these powers
we have to remember that we have them
and call them forth
in relevant situations so a lot of
wonderful little insights there
now if i can end on a personal note when
my oldest son was little i used to love
to sit and watch the old he-man cartoons
with him
in virtually every episode during a time
of crisis
prince adam holds his sword aloft in the
air
says by the power of grayskull it's
struck by all this lightning you know
most appropriate for a lightning round
then adam says i have the power as he's
transformed
into this herculean uh he-man so i like
to think that in a sense epithelius is
telling us
that we have the power not by gray skull
but powers within our own every one of
our own skulls
now not the power necessary to become a
he-man or a she-ra
but the powers to deal with all the
kinds of temptations and frustrations
we deal with in the course of our daily
lives or even in the course
of a pandemic so i'll just end by noting
i hope every one of us will remember
especially during trying times that
epictetus has told each and every one of
us
you have the power thank you
hi everyone it's great to be here with
you during this season of stoicism
i wanted to share an idea with you
that's really helped me in my stoic
journey as i try to become a more
excellent person
and i hope it helps you as well it's the
idea that we all have the seeds of
virtue within us
the ancient stoics were big believers in
human nature
they say that we are rational or social
we have everything in us to become
excellent virtuous people and i think
this idea is very valuable because we
can think about
kind of watering the seeds of virtue and
nurturing what's already inside us
rather than rooting out what's already
there and trying to replace it with
something else
we can think in terms of nurturing what
we have
so there are two ways that we can really
develop this one is
giving ourselves the right environment
just like you would a plant
and another is by withdrawing or drawing
up what we already have
so the first one our environment think
about the influences that you have
around you we live in a very complex
world
we all have a lot of information a lot
of different influences
coming at us all the time so try to
reduce the negative ones as much as you
can
you're never going to be able to reduce
everything unless you completely
withdraw from the world
but as stoics that's not what we want to
do we want to stay engaged
but as you as you're consuming social
media or traditional media
think about those messages that are
coming at you you might want to start
noticing
how many of them are actually really
negative
and try to either set your filter
and filter out the the really negative
ones or the ones that are not reliable
and or just kind of reduce your
consumption you can't
get rid of it all together but reduce as
much as you can maybe once or twice a
day you check the news
something like that instead of having a
steady stream of negative commentary
coming at you all the time at the same
time you want to replace that as much as
you can with positive influences
so looking to classical literature or
fiction non-fiction whatever sources
help you
help guide your mind towards something
more positive towards becoming an
excellent person
of course stoic podcasts and stoic
material stoic books everything is
really helpful
so try to feed your mind just like if
you were growing a garden
you want to weed out the negative things
and feed your mind you know
good fertilizer the other thing that we
can do
is think about what we already have so
like i said before we don't want to root
out what's there
we want to nurture what's there the way
you can do this
is for example if you're working on
anger management
you would say okay i'm not angry all the
time in this situation maybe
my boss said something to me or i got
caught off by another driver
and i was still okay i didn't get angry
think about how you can apply what you
did in that situation
to other situations give yourself credit
you're not an angry person
every second of the day are you so draw
that out into other situations
be very deliberate about it i would
recommend maybe in your morning
meditation
you identify a situation where you're
prone to getting angry
and then you say okay in that situation
i'm going to keep my mind clear in a
good place
and then you do it and check in with
yourself in the evening
or if you tend to buy too many things on
amazon
or you you need to work harder at
something whatever your issue is and we
all have things that we need to improve
at
be very deliberate about it think about
a situation where you can do that thing
maybe you were browsing amazon one day
and you didn't buy five books that you
wanted
think about how you can do that again
and apply it to other situations
so again we're watering the seeds that
we already have within us
instead of kind of cutting down
everything and starting fresh
so this idea has really helped me on my
stoic journey
and i hope it helps you as well thank
you so much take care
hello my name is nick mulroy and i was
recently given the privilege
of doing a paper in a podcast for modern
stoicism
the paper was predominantly about the
need to start teaching ethics and
morality
in our schools again it is a topic that
is just
important science or history or any
other
and it is at the core of our society
whether we trust one another has a lot
to do
with whether we are individually ethical
i started learning about stoicism
as a young man my father decided to
teach ethics
not from a religious doctrine but from
greek philosophy and he focused
primarily on
plato's republic and socrates
which i know is not necessarily stoic
but i believe socrates is at the core of
stoicism
as you can see clearly illustrated
in the story of zeno and his shipwreck
and then as a young man i joined the us
marine corps
and i served with the marine corps
for a career i also served with the
central intelligence
agency as a career and eventually ended
up
as a as a senior policy maker in our
department of defense
all of those told me that the core
principles
as i see him of stoicism should be
prevalent
in our government the us government and
every government for that matter
justice courage tempers
temperance and most importantly wisdom
science deniers should not be a part
of our government
we need to be able to trust each other
we need to be able to trust
in our ability to reason to reach the
conclusions and meet the challenges
that we as a nation are going to face
and the world's going to face be it
climate change be it a constant struggle
for limited resources
and overpopulation all of these are
coming
and whether we meet them and we're up
for the challenge or not
i think we'll largely come back to
whether we are
in fact good people and whether we can
actually
trust one another my next project
is going to be to learn more about
stoicism because although i think i've
been learning about it my whole life
i do not claim to be in any way an
expert
i'm starting my education
now and i look forward to meeting you
and i look forward to we can have
conferences in person my next project is
going to be on stoicism in the military
i always thought that was a well-known
um issue but from
discussions recently i found out it is
not so i'll be working on that
so i'd like to conclude by thanking dr
stadler for inviting me to give this
video and i look forward to learning
more about stoicism
hi everyone my name is dr debbie joffee
ellis and it's my
pleasure to contribute to this segment
of
lightning talks at stoicon hi to all my
stoicon friends
so some of you may or may not know that
my late
husband dr albert ellis
was a very important shall
i say ambassador for stoicism
in the 20th and early 21st century
al pioneered
or shall i say heralded in the cognitive
revolution in psychotherapy
and a very significant part
of his approach of rational emotive
behavior therapy
is the tenant originated as far as we
know
by epictetus which says
that it's not events that create our
emotions
but our perceptions of the events
those may not be the literal words that
epic
titus wrote but that was the meaning
and al would acknowledge epictetus and
marcus aurelius and
other great stoic thinkers and writers
and and that energy is very much
part of our ebt
rational emotive behavior therapy
i loved to read and he
loved stoicism and i pulled out this
book this
precious book i i love books and i love
this one so much
discourses and then carried him of
epictetus
and al read this
repetitively at various times
look at it i i'm very careful with it it
was published in 1899
and the way al read books was
i'm just opening here at a random page
to underlying points that he liked
if he really liked them he would do a a
check mark if he didn't i'm looking um
i can't find one here that he would do a
cross and and if he wasn't sure or still
reflecting um he would write
question marks there and earlier before
i start recording i just
opened to this random page um
well wildlife and that's my bookmark
this isn't from 1890 or 1899.
anyway and and just again enjoyed seeing
evidence of how he thought about things
really questioned
and one of the things he underlined and
clearly agreed with was
regulate your will throw away your wrong
principles and that is so much
part of the philosophy
of our psychotherapeutic approach
where we teach the importance
of thinking in rational ways
particularly
when challenging and or brutal things
happen
so that we can cope more effectively
you know al and i taught i continue to
teach
that when we think in rational ways we
create
healthy emotions when we think in
irrational ways
we create unhealthy debilitating
emotions
and we have a choice we have a choice
once we're aware that we have a choice
so anyway that's my little bit for this
lightning talk i hope it interests you
here's my handsome alligator
and i wish all of you that you keep
safe and
think in healthy ways choose choose
choose to keep things in perspective and
every day to focus on what we still can
be grateful for
despite and including difficulties
around us and in our lives
so wishing you all the best
bye for now
hello my name is caleb i am a programmer
philosopher
and founder of stoa a stoic meditation
app
you can find it on the play store or the
app store it has a library of stoic
meditations
and conversations with people like
massimo pilucci
donald robertson and greg sadler
so today i'm going to be talking about
the nature of emotion
let's take two ways of responding to
feelings
on one hand you have someone who
represses their feelings this person
bottles everything up they seek to be
coal iron fortress
never disturbed by pain or anxiety you
can call this person the repressive
then there's someone for whom every
feeling determines their reality
if they feel sad and the entire world is
colored in their sadness
they have thoughts like i am not loved
the world is unjust and
unfair nothing works yet if they're
happy
then the world is colored in a much
brighter way
this person is at the mercy of their
feelings you can call this person
the roller coaster i believe these two
persons
the repressive and the roller coaster
are making the same kind of mistake
they are confusing feelings and emotions
this idea is hinted at by seneca on
anger
he has this line where a man thinks
himself injured
wants to be revenged and then dissuaded
for some reason
he quickly calms down again i don't call
this anger but
a mental impulse yielding to reason
anger is that which overleaps reason and
carries it away
there are these two states that seneca
is describing you have mental impulse
this is what we call feeling and then
emotion
this is the judgment of whether or this
state is actually good or bad
sensations in the body what it's like to
be in an effective state this is
the feeling and then the judgments for
the story for what is going on
whether it's ultimately good or bad is
this is an emotion
so the repressive has made the mistake
of judging that negative feelings are
bad ultimately bad they then bottle them
up they need to be avoided because
they are bad and this results in
ignoring the usefulness of feelings
the rollercoaster on the other hand has
made the mistake of allowing feelings to
dictate their reason as soon as they
experience
a given states it becomes their full
reality what is
true they move too quickly from feeling
to
judgment of the emotion
so margaret graver in stories animation
extends this idea
she has the following passage if the
psychic sensations we experience in
emotion are not identical
with the pathing then the norm of apathy
does not need to be cashed out as an
injunction against every human feeling
one might be impassive in the stoic
sense and still remain subject to other
categories of effective experience
so the stoic attitude towards emotion
reorients our perspective towards the
correct judgment
and virtues that's what is ultimately
important it's not about
avoiding negative feelings becoming
wrapped up in
positive feelings it's about seeing the
world as it is
and focusing on living well
thanks
this happened
that was my friend coming to meet me
after his class where he just learned
about stoicism
my friend knew that i battled with
social anxiety and thought that
stoicism could be helpful i was
skeptical stoic
that's oppressive right i'm trying to be
myself i want to be expansive
not restrictive
then he told me about the real stoicism
it's our thoughts that make us
anxious and he quoted epictetus
men are not troubled by things
themselves but by their thoughts about
them
it struck me as weird although stoicism
is ancient the direct link between
thoughts and emotion recently became
very
familiar to me
that sounds like cbt
i hate cbt it doesn't work for me
yes i said it like that he continued
now about what you can control some
things are in our control
and others not
things in our control are opinion
pursuit desire aversion
and in a word whatever are our own
actions things not in our control our
body
property reputation command and in one
word
whatever are not our actions it was the
dichotomy of control and when he said
that quote
i knew that i wanted to find out about
stoicism
you see the quote so well encapsulated
the best
of what was taught to me as a patient in
a mental health facility
i remember so well a session in which
the patients were naming things we can
control
and that went on one side of the
whiteboard and things we could not
control
and that went on the other side
so for me that made an enormous
cognitive shift
and that was agency i could always do
something if i feel stuck in despair i
could go for a walk
if i feel insignificant i can express
myself in art
if i just don't have the will to get up
out of bed i can at least take a few
deep breaths
sometimes it's baby steps but it's good
to know that
i can control what i do
during that session i heard the word
stinkin
thinkin changing that stinking
programming
is what cbt or cognitive behavioral
cognitive behavioral therapy is really
all about
i didn't understand this about cbt until
i became acquainted with stoicism
stoicism teaches a way of living that
will gradually
shift the thinking patterns to ones that
are more
helpful and wholesome cbt
when conducted properly does this
effectively as well
now bear with me this talk is about
stoicism
i'm going to go back to cbt for just
just a moment
in group therapy application was helpful
medicine
it was idiosyncratic i could pick and
choose those ideas
that were beneficial to me at that
particular time
but in one-on-one therapy i got the
mistaken
impression that cbt was one size fits
all
i don't feel like i can do it well
have you tried cbt just tell yourself
you could do it
pusha
the greater part of my life i tried
personal pep talks and gave it up in
despair
that's what i thought cbt was a reminder
of
my failure
according to the founder of cbt though
each individual warrants an approach
that fits
their particular thought and behavior
cbt needs to be individualized to be
really
effective the point i want to make is
stoicism is that way too
if you're still deciding whether
stoicism would be helpful to you
or if you just want more bang for the
buck with your stoic discipline
consider this think about
how you can make it more yours
consider your values your endeavors
and find stoic practices
that resonate with that
and tailor it to yourself for example if
phrase like
it's nothing to me doesn't sit well then
try something else
like it can't stop me from being the
person that i
want to be the point of stoic practice
is not that's to make stoics
be and act the same stoicism is designed
to help
individual me and you
to thrive
hi this is dr mary bryan bates recording
from the banks of the pawtucketway
for stowacon x the midwestern version
i'm going to be talking today about the
benefits
of having a life philosophy
for patients i've previously talked
about
my reluctance to talk with patients
about this
issue um because i feel like i'm not an
expert in
philosophy um but today i'm going to
talk
about the benefits of um
patients having this um
the most common manifestation of lacking
life philosophy that i see
is depression and anxiety i see
patients um who
have um both depression and anxiety as
well as the common manifest
the common um sequela of depression
and anxiety um
the most um a frequent root cause of
depression that i
see is having to face an un a difficult
decision
all of the options are unpalatable um
often the patient will know which option
feels right to them but it will come
along with
accompaniments that they feel are
unacceptable um and
sometimes stoicism can give them a
different way to evaluate their options
which can really help them get
unstuck sometimes stoicism can reframe
the question or the options and that can
really be helpful
um stoicism is also really good at
helping people
find a way to deal with discomfort
and so stoicism can often help people
figure out
how the unpalatable options can be
a little bit more palatable
um people who are depressed are more
likely to die from their heart attacks
more likely to have out of control
diabetes having depression makes it
harder to control one's weight
which worsens once joint pain and
non-specific inflammation
finding the motivation to exercise is
difficult when you're depressed and then
people are more likely to
become weaker to fall to have fractures
um and
poor balance and also um
when they and also insomnia when they
don't exercise
um another condition which a life
philosophy helps
with is anxiety excuse me
um the internet is filled with articles
about how stoicism is helpful for
anxiety
um my clinic is filled with anxious
people
anxiety tends to worsen people's blood
pressure to cause them to be suspicious
of
all of their symptoms and to um to have
unnecessary
workups which are expensive and then
discover
meaningless abnormalities which then
cause them to embark upon
further um medical workups
people who are anxious
are reluctant to leave their house they
often become reluctant to
engage in exercise that needs to happen
outside of their house
less exercise we've already talked about
the downsides to that
stoicism can be
[Music]
helpful for anxiety
and
[Music]
depression but it can also be um helpful
when you're trying to find the
motivation for doing something that is
beneficial for yourself
i often find that people who have a hard
time doing things that are beneficial
for themselves
have no problems at all with doing
things that are beneficial for other
people it's almost as though they feel
they themselves are not worthy of
self-care
um stoicism has um
great ideas about having a legitimate
place in the universe
and being worthy of care oneself which
can be very helpful
for um for people
who are struggling with this issue
stoicism can also be helpful
when you're trying to make a difficult
medical decision
um the first question i often ask people
when they're faced with a
treatment decision is what makes life
worth
living knowing this guides the decision
about one
what one is willing to sacrifice for
what else for example maybe
someone is willing to sacrifice quality
of life right now for quantity
of life or maybe one is not willing to
sacrifice that
um the older one gets the more important
the question
of what makes life worth living becomes
when you get a bad diagnosis
it's not a good time to figure out what
your life philosophy is
having life philosophy can also be
helpful for having making consistent
responses to the world
if you aim at one goal one day and then
another goal another day you're unlikely
to get
either goal for example if you are aimed
at
maximizing the pleasure of your life at
this moment
um that you might make decisions that
make it harder for you
to then um care for the grandchildren
later which um because you
yourself might require medical care um
or you know personal care and this um
thus one ends up with a situation where
they're
unlikely to get either um
so having life philosophy can be really
helpful for
making consistent decisions this has
been a brief
overview of the manner in which i think
having a life philosophy can be
beneficial for patients
sorry i heard a squirrel
um stoicism is a good philosophy to
share with patients because it can be
effective for depression
and the decision paralysis which often
underlies depression
um it can be helpful with anxiety it can
provide people with motivation for
taking care of themselves
having life philosophy helps people when
they have to make difficult
treatment decisions i don't think
that philosophy is going to replace
sglt2 inhibitors or ssris anytime in the
near future
but i do think that having a philosophy
and being able to discuss
philosophy with patients and being
comfortable suggesting to patients that
they consider the importance of
philosophy
is a good trick to add to the doctor bag
i'm dr mary brown
bates this is uh stoicon x the midwest
version
thank you
hello i am harold and i study philosophy
in ancient greek at university of oslo
i would like to begin by thanking greg
sadler for inviting me
the topic that i want to discuss today
is what it means to be a diamond
according to epictetus
a demon is an adjective that derives
from the word idols
which can be translated as either
reverence or
shame or sense of shame and a diamond is
often translated into
modest self-respecting or having a sense
of shame
this might be different in the united
states but at least my nature country
shame is mostly considered to be
something negative
and having a sense of shame is
considered to be a bit old-fashioned
however i think that both feeling
ashamed and especially
having a sense of shame is important for
our moral development
and i think that epictetus would have
agreed with that
epictetus even thought that our sense of
shame is part one nature
it says that our nature is to be people
who are free
noble-minded and self-respecting i
dammit
for what other animal blushes what other
animal has a sense of
shame that's from three seven
i will focus on two points a sense of
shame
is something that can be built up or
broken down
and a sense of shame is connected to
epictetus's
role ethics the feeling of shame
is something that can be built up and
broken down
by our actions in the same way that
arizona believes that we become
righteous by doing righteous acts
epic says that we break down our sense
of shame by doing shameful acts and
build up
by acting in accordance with our sense
of shame
we see this among other places in
discourse 2
4 where a picture speaks to a person who
has apparently gone after another man's
wife epictetus claims that by doing so
he is destroying his sense of shame
which in turn destroys a sense of
community
he also writes that dress as a carpenter
and a grammarian preserves his
techne his craft by performing it
skillfully
and breaks it down by doing the opposite
a person will break down
his sense of shame by doing shameful
acts and build up by acting in
accordance with it
in the discourses 210 with their kind of
hierarchical approach to the rules
which epictetus tries to use to
deduce our appropriate actions from
uh we begin by assessing what is
appropriate for us in virtue of being
humans
and since humans are rational social
creatures the appropriate action for us
will be
rational and social actions further down
in the hierarchy
there are other roles which we have in
virtue of being for instance
a father or a citizen and so on
we can derive appropriate actions based
in part on our role as human beings and
more specifically in virtually having
certain relationships with other people
and positions in a society in all cases
an appropriate action will be something
that involves playing our roles in a
good way
idols comes into the picture when we see
the tension between how we should live
and how we actually live especially with
regards to our role as
humans that is rational and social
uh epicurus writes you carry god around
with you
poor rich and yet you have no knowledge
of it
you suppose that i mean some external
god gold or silver
this within yourself that you carry him
and you fail to realize that you're
defiling him through
imperial thoughts and unclean actions
yet
in front of a divine image you wouldn't
dare to do
any of the things that you do but when
god himself
is present within you and he sees and
hears everything
aren't you ashamed to think and act as
you do you who are
ignorant of your own nature and are an
object of divine
anger that's from 2-8
epictetus main point here since because
our kinship with god
ought to be something that we ought to
keep in mind when we are living our
lives
and he appeals to his human sense of
shame in order to get
the point across i think that is quite
possible for us
to bring our sense of shame into our
understanding of our different roles
for instance i as a student might use my
sense of shame in a situation
where i am tempted to ignore my
obligation
obligations as a student by going out
and get drunk
so to conclude epictetus
thinks that shame and a sense of shame
is essential feature of being human
shame is related to our understanding of
who we are and what role we should play
and how we should do so
shame can be a motivator for developing
virtue
and a sense of community and
consequently shame is not something that
we should try to
rid ourselves of in every possible case
the tricky part is to get our sense of
shame to hit
the right target
if you want to read more about this i
can recommend uh
an essay by rakana kantikar from 1998
called idos in epictetus
all of the translations that i've used
today
come from robin hart and his translation
of the discourses
thank you for having me
i discovered stoicism when i was still
in my
teens since then i've been practicing
some form of stoicism
but all these years i never call myself
a stoic
i didn't discuss it with anyone about
four years ago i decided to write a book
on stoicism almost all my friends were
surprised
even my brother asked me how i knew
about stoicism
i don't normally discuss my beliefs with
anyone even now
i don't call myself a liberal a
conservative a christian
an atheist or even a stoic
this is because at some level i always
believed
what swarm kierkegaard said when you
label me
you negate me the moment i say i'm a
story
someone would ask me to explain stoicism
to them
someone would ask me why i want to be a
story
someone would ask me why that i don't
behave like a story
someone would say i behave too much like
a story
this label starts defining me i become a
slave to that label
it diminishes me it negates me so i
never call myself a story all was well
with the world
with this philosophy until about four
years ago
then i got interested in stoicism
seriously
i wrote some 15 books on stoicism i
spoke at story conferences
i started a digital magazine in the
story
the word was out i'm a stoic people
asked me what
racism was sometimes while riding an
elevator
so it's time for me to have my elevator
pitch
handy it's not enough for an elevator
pitch to be shot
it should be accurate it should be
understandable and relatable
it should not put the listener off after
some trial and error
i came up with this here it is
some things in life are under our
control some things in our life
are not under our control our life
starts going wrong
when we lose this distinction let me
give you an example
it's friday you get the word you are
fired
you are upset and you are dejected
directed
in the evening you had planned to go out
for a dinner
with a friend can you enjoy the dinner
if you're like most people you cannot
enjoy the dinner how can you
you just lost your job just look at this
closely you are upset about losing your
job
something you have no control over you
refuse to enjoy your dinner a
thing or a thing over which you have
total control
suppose you reverse this you are not
going to worry about losing your job
because you're not you can do nothing
about it you are going to enjoy your
meal
because it is under your control and it
is right in front of you
every moment of every day if you ask
yourself
what things do i have control over now
then your life will be very different
for example
right now you cannot you can you can
decide you can enjoy your meal you can
sleep well you can take it easy over the
weekend
and on monday you can call a couple of
employment agencies
spruce up your linkedin resume put the
word out
that you are looking for a job
unfortunately most of us do
exactly the opposite we worry about
things
that were no control over we failed to
act on things that we do have control
over
this is the main reason why our life
doesn't work
as well as it should so whenever you are
worried
whenever you are anxious whenever you
are upset ask a single question
is this under my control if it is not
it's nothing to you
if it is ask yourself what can i do
that's under my control do those things
your anxieties and worries will be gone
just by applying this one principle most
likely
this is my floors so maybe i can get off
the elevator
oh but i live on the 43rd floor of a
hotel maybe there's not my floria
so i continue now our anxiety is gone
our worries are gone our life
can become even better if you realize
three more things
number one you need a lot less than you
think
to be happy and fulfilled so moderate
your desires
number two you have the resources to
face whatever may happen in the future
don't fear anything external number
three
your happiness does not depend on what
others have or do
so be just in all your dealings with
others
stories consider these four principles
practical wisdom
moderation courage and justice has full
virtues
they taught taught us that all we need
to lead the good life
are these four principles oh this
is my floor nice talking to you bye
hi mark de chase here from the new
england stoix first
a big thank you to greg sadler the
milwaukee stoic fellowship
for hosting still connects midwest 2020
my topic today is stoicism
and meditation i'd like to look at it
from
by comparing and contrasting the two
looking seeing it from a historical
perspective and
since it's stoicism and it's a practical
philosophy
let's practice
what in what ways are they different
meditation is eastern
it's experiential it's self-reflective
and focused on meaning
stoicism on the other hand is western
rational it
engages in the world and is a
materialistic point of view
where do they where are they the same
well both
disciplines have attention at their core
the the focus on impressions both true
and false
the present awareness and significantly
the breath or pneuma in greek
while they were heavily influential on
the stoics they came several
hundred years before xeno the
pythagoreans
they advocated both morning
and evening reflection they greeted the
sun
and thought about their place in the
universe in the morning
walking in silence and in the evening
didn't let
sleep past their eyes until three times
they'd gone over the events of the day
not only to reflect on the day but also
as a memory exercise
zeno the founder of stoicism focused on
reason and a smooth current of life
penicius the last athenian scallark
or head of the stoic school in athens
said one needs a mind that is always
ready
and alert so alertness reason these are
very
rational disciplines and pursuits
epictetus in the later stowa said is
anything
is there anything that could be made
worse by attention or
better by inattention he was very much
into focus and attention
in book four of his discourses
marcus aurelius influenced heavily by
epictetus said
do away with judgment and the notion
i've been harmed
is done away with do away with that
notion and the harm itself is gone
in today's terms that we would call this
metacognition or cognitive distancing
here are five ideas for practicing stoic
influenced meditation be like the
pythagoreans and in the morning
reflect on the day ahead and in the
evening think back on your day
you can do this with recordings or just
by journaling
or just by thinking about it each day
twice a day
preferably take a meditation break
even if you set your timer for five
minutes a day
take a break from work and practice
tranquility you'll come back refreshed
take a walk go outside be alert like
penacious
and experience your senses
during a conversation pay very close
attention like epictetus would
and most of all treat life as a
meditation
practice like marcus would non-judgment
and acceptance i'd like to end
by having a 30-second practice of
meditation
ending with a gong
here are some links with more
information including our thursday night
new england stoics stoic influence
meditation
thank you very much
you